movies are a fully sensory experience
heard and felt as well as seen but
without the handiwork of sound mixers
and sound editors they'd be lost
destroy imagining star wars without the
hum and switch to the lightsabers a
Jurassic Park will have the roar of the
t-rex well luckily we don't have to
thanks to the gifted men and women who
bring the movies to life through the
magic of sound is that me I think so oh
and here are the nominees for achieving
the sound mix with you sorry in Sigma
captain Phillips Chris burden Mark
Taylor mic pres would Smith and Chris
Monroe gravity skip let's say Nev a
Deary
Christopher Ben stub and Kris Munroe the
hobbit the desolation of smaug
christopher boys Michael Hedges
Mikaelson manic and Tony Johnson inside
Llewyn Davis skip let's say Gregor law
and Peter F Berlin lone survivors and
Equis Emma beau borders and David Brown
Rhodes the Oscar goes to gravity skip
Twain said leave any your personal
benefit
Thank You Academy members and thank you
very much to our fearless leader Alfonzo
where we are we want to thank you for
your amazing incredible vision and also
for your incredible patience we'd also
like to thank David Heyman Nicki penny
Warner Brothers and our fantastic team
of production sound people and
post-production people who worked very
hard on this movie and I would like to
thank my life Elizabeth and my children
Brandon Henry wherever you are I love
you very much and of course
Sandra and George for bringing reality
to the unreal Chris and Nev would like
to thank their families for bringing us
all down to earth and right now we're
over the moon thank you thank you